[Musique]
mesdemoiselles messieurs antenne 2 et
philips l'inventeur du compact disc vous
présente la nouvelle émission de thierry
ardisson
je
tiens
[Musique]
et
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue
le jeu
allah
j'en arrive
jalousement
patrick sébastien
j'imagine
d'entrée
tantric tissu
j'en veux
on l'a vu avec les terrans
bonsoir
et là mais loisel messieurs bonsoir
bienvenue aux folies bergères pour
double je
notre émission de ce soir sera un derby
régional saint tropez contre monaco
sex-symbol des années 50 60 70 80 90
toujours délicieuse et ravissante
brigitte bardot
la seule
picotte son altesse sérénissime
stéphanie grimaldi de monaco qui nous
revient d'une tournée triomphale au
bistrot d'en face
après juste toi qui défend les grands
singes tu t'occupes de qui en ce moment
en ce moment je m'occupe de jayan et
demis roussos et une année ou de ta
lutte contre la vivisection
pour michael jackson justin a pu faire
assez dommage
régis dites moi pourquoi avez-vous fait
castrer votre âme comme j'en sais
quelque chose
stéphanie paris match et sur les dents
quel est le prochain malheur qui va
s'abattre sur la principauté gêné sortir
un nouvel album en janvier
c'est vrai qu'on fait depuis toutes tes
robes je m'en fout de toute façon je
collectionne a cédé face en ce moment
franchement tu aurais pas a préféré
arriver vierge au mariage c'est
difficile de se marier à 8 ans
la semaine dernière sacrée soirée rendu
un bel hommage à double jeu on nous
empruntons une idée de rubriques cette
semaine double jeu a décidé de rendre le
même hommage à tf1 est ce soir notre
invité est un invité mystère
tendez j'attends j'attends invité
mystère et ce bout qui avait déclaré
juste avant la guerre du golfe que la
france devait y participer pour pouvoir
être présente aux négociations de la
conférence de paix non bon c'est pas
françois mitterrand invité mystère est
ce que vous avez reconnu tous vos
enfants oui c'est pas une vente en
invité mystère est ce que ça vous brûle
quand vous fait pipi
j'ai trouvé ces bigard c'est jean marie
bigard
et
[Musique]
tournon digard prénom jean marie c'est
tout après jean marie marcelle des
surnoms je te demande ouais j'en avais
un que j'étais à l'école m'appeler bigou
état ppa t'appelles comment elle
c'est un appel palcy fait la fed à
thomas n'appelle pas trop date de
naissance 17 mai 54 alors l'étaient les
cheveux gras mouillé gras ou salés
qu'ils sont normaux et je t'emmerde pas
mal les dieux avoir les yeux des yeux
marrons j'ai deux cochons a démenti
ouais il permettra je suis hyper mettra
fait ça c'est pas beau me vanter mais je
les voyais bien non je m'appelle jean
marie mais il ya des limites quand même
cicatrices oui j'en ai connu une petite
c'est une ride d'expression on appelle
ça plaît aux femmes est pareil c'est dû
à quoi ça c'est dû à quoi tu je te pose
des questions mais je suis demande luta
https veste et attaquant du de fringues
doit asie continue mais tu commence un
peu à me courir sur le haricot je dis
tout de suite et les verrues non j'ai
arrêté je t ai deux paquets par jour
j'ai arrêté supporter des slips
oui disciple de tarzan des fois ça
dépend dans quelle part tous tu vas ça
dépend tu fais me conviennent paquet par
joueur ça dépend chum si je fais la
ribouldingue fumeux deux ennemis et
qu'une bouteille de whisky puis sinon
j'allume des fois ma première clope
avant de jouer le soir tout va
je fume trois quatre clubs dans la
journée savent que je quand je me mets
quoi c'est une question de volonté jédir
on peut fumer davantage faut s'accrocher
du tout est ce que tu as des rapports
sexuels ailleurs que dans un lit mais je
te demande bien sûr toi aussi je suppose
ou par exemple a partout machine à laver
en position et sa rage as tu eu recours
à l'amour tarifé à l'amour tarifé oui ça
m'est déjà arrivé d'aller voir une [ __ ]
c'est ça oui apparu clairement pas ce
qu'on peut pour bompas jeu et ça s'est
passé comment ça c'est vachement bien
passé mais quand je suis arrivé à paris
premier truc que j'ai fait c'est d'aller
aux [ __ ]
j'étais fasciné bescond provinciaux n'a
pas beaucoup l'annonçaient c'est
vraiment un défi qu'ils peuvent pour
faire autre chose tadic à paris mais il
y en a des belles et toupie j'étais
fasciné à l'idée de donner de l'argent à
une fille pour qu'elle me suce la beach
mais ça tu vois c'est tellement un
échange st je trouve que c'est vachement
plus 5 la secrétaire qui donne son cul
de voir l'augmentation fausse un plus
plus propre et est souvent ces défis
formidable ça ma femme elle ne verra pas
suffi non tu viennes combien par mois
s'il ya une pas mal de pognon je gagne
je gagne bien ma vie
combien combien se calment pas content
j'ai une société moi aussi je gagne un
petit peu je grosso modo que tu joues au
théâtre vassal
ça fait de vous ça peut friser les cinq
cent mille balles
par mois bah comme tout le monde un
regard encore agi tout seul là c'est pas
mal tous les jours je veux dire nous
incombe à 1500 milles et puis un coup on
gagne 300 milles c'est pas on n'est pas
à l'abri
moi qui gagne 6 milles mais c'est tous
les mois c'est tombe c'est une sécurité
pour avec nous on n'est jamais à l'abri
des trucs tout moment ça peut varier
d'un moment à l'autre
tiens toi qu'un comique fait moins rire
ah ah quel con
notre invité ce soir là venez le
séductrice de la nouvelle vague
la madone des travellings intello voici
tu parce que je suis là j'ai la mémoire
qui flanche j'me souviens plus très bien
de quelle couleur était ses yeux il
était noir ou bleu à 6 j'adore
vous connaissez nos amis on va très bien
on était voisins quand j'habitais los
angeles en 77 alors jeanne vous vous
êtes mariés
la première fois c'était en 49 avec jean
richard que changer son nom parce que ça
ressemblait à jean richard hein et vous
est retrouvée enceinte est en fait le
mariage a eu lieu la veille de
l'accouchement
un samedi c'est gratuit et puis c'était
juste avant oui c'était juste avant ce
qui fait que le photographe il était
obligé de l'art descendez l'escalier on
m'avait prêté un grand manteau et je dis
ah non non pas de telle manière mais
madame la tête seulement si vous n'aviez
pas été enceintes vous seriez marier
quand même non
c'est franck vous avez un enfant ou
jérôme qui a 42 ans aujourd'hui ni vous
le voyez souvent tu le vois en ce moment
à peu près une fois par an via en
californie ce que vous dites j'ai eu un
enfant mais je n'ai jamais été maire
c'est dur à dire ça quand même et non
pas du tout je suis maire ce que je dis
je m'étais maman donataire moteur
maintenant pernel dans le sens
conventionnel
ensuite vous avez eu une liaison je suis
pas secret avec pierre cardin
oui et puis vous vous êtes mariés pour
la deuxième fois avec leurs réalisations
pas un vrai amour un regard de la wii ça
dure et qu'en même temps ça durait plus
4 en 1 et puis après vous être marié ou
donc avec le réalisateur de l'exorciste
et de french connection william friedkin
mobile vous êtes mariés parce que ça
vous a touché qui vous demande en
mariage et ça m'a beaucoup car c'est la
première fois qu'on vous demandait en
mariage vous avez des en fait oui alors
ce divorce était quelque chose
d'épouvantable vous parlez de d'années
noires
le fait que j'ai accepté je lui accorder
une valeur un peu sacré et j'ai souffert
de cette disproportion entre mon désir
et la réalité
non pas que je me sentais responsable et
non pas que je le trouvais lui
responsable mais ça a été une douleur
très violente et très profonde
ça vous a coûté de l'argent en plus ça
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave enfin
vous n'étiez pas très au courant des
banquiers des avocats tout ça ou vous
n'êtes pas voulu être au courant non
c'est pas grave j'étais surtout la
déchirure qui quand elle vous dit
je ne pense pas dans ma vie avoir aimé
un homme à avoir il a non c'est pas
grave du tout un bon je le reconnais je
veille à la plupart des gens sont comme
moi on est amoureux on est passionnément
attaché on repousse violemment mais
l'amour l'alliance ce que j'appelle
l'alliance c'est à dire un échange
profond à désintéresser un amour absolu
je n'ai pas connu en tout cas moi je ne
vais pas connu vous regrettez oui
quelque part j'espère le connaître avant
de mourir oui mais peut-être que ça ne
sera pas sous la forme que tout le monde
peut imaginer maintenant on va voir un
sujet car elle avoir ça vous changer les
idées s'est consacré à la guerre
[Musique]
en janvier 1993 lorsque douvres sera
relié à calais par le tunnel sous la
manche l'angleterre ne sera plus tout à
fait une île la manche qui a toujours
préservé le royaume uni des invasions ne
pourra plus alors jouer son rôle de
rempart naturel contre l'ennemi le
secret défense est maintenant levé et le
times du 11/9 an dernier révèle que le
tunnel peut être inondée en cas de
conflit au moment de la signature du
traité
j'en ai moins en a eu vent de
une préparatifs qu'il se faisait pour la
défense nationale anglaise qui a demandé
le changement au plan du tunnel mais
nous ne savions pas quoi exactement
personnes voulaient nous dire c'était un
secret nous avons insisté auprès des des
gens à londres des milices être en ce
moment et de défense sans rien moi
jusqu'à récemment quand je pense le
gouvernement anglais a voulu calmer un
peu les inquiétudes du public anglaise
de qu'est-ce qui se passerait aucun où
il ya un vase ion
est ce que quelque chose de sérieux
était prévu sur ordre du premier
ministre britannique
löw pourra s'engouffrer dans le tunnel
grâce à une série de conduire liés au
fond de la mer en quelques heures la
partie centrale du tunnel sera inondé
soit treize des 37 ni de matinée sous la
manche
et selon le times et le 20 janvier 1986
le jour de la signature du traité sur le
tunnel ferroviaire que le principe d'un
dispositif de sécurité fut adopté une
destruction par l'armé nucléaire et en
définitive tom quinn ministre de la
défense de l'époque préféra le système
d'inondations qui permet une remise en
état ultérieure du tunnel mais le tunnel
at il une réelle importance stratégique
pour le gouvernement britannique il est
très important de neutraliser le tunnel
parce que c'est le meilleur moyen d'une
occupation terrestre
aujourd'hui certes on fait d'abord la
guerre avec l'aviation avec les missiles
mais il s'agit ensuite de concrétiser la
victoire par une conquête terrestre est
donc coupée le tunnel c'est freiner une
invasion mais rappelez-vous ce
stratagème a déjà été utilisé dans
l'histoire alors mais il serait il entré
dans les services secrets britanniques
suite
inondable en cas de guerre s de l'info
est de l'intox
jeanne moreau à l'oreille j'aimerais
bien gagner ouais ouais non maintenant
pendant que vous chercher chez vous pour
savoir si c'est de l'info si c'est de
l'intox
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute partie il y avait
tout à fait l'image contre les guerriers
du repos plus est la préférée d'ardisson
c'est la plus sexy du show business on a
là mardi soir viennent s'en méfier
l'appel unique lisa ce thème fille ouais
étiez vous
allez marine chez eux c
du marbre
[Musique]
m
mais pour
[Musique]
non mais
le tunnel sous la manche inondable en
cas de guerre s de l'info s de l'intox
c'est à charles de jouer at on avait dit
que c'est de l'intox
tu dis que c'est de l'intox tout a été
calculé depuis longtemps ouais et toi
charge alors je peux le dire maintenant
jeanne m'a dit que c'était de l'intox on
va voir si vous avez chanté toute la
chanson où seulement trois couples et
philippe chan se croient que vous faites
une quinzaine d'émissions avec nous vous
allez très très forte à ce jeu là
puisque vous avez gagné bravo c'était de
l'intox
je vais être obligé de s'exécuter jeanne
de nos chantiers la chanson bull elles
sont toutes bien j'aime ton odeur ta
saveurs les autres t'es pas vos nyon
tu as les cheveux longs mais je t'ai
dans la peau mais je t'ai dans la peau
les os je ne suis pas joli joli
nous ne sommes pas bo bobo mais entre
toi moi je grille
tu me fout le feu à la peau
tu as peut-être pas des bras d'athlètes
tu as peut-être pas le torse velu
mais j'adore retenir est chaque fois tu
dis que tu m'as dans la peau lit on dans
ce camion bravo
au revoir
[Musique]
mon choix
je à plisser vous êtes très beau je le
fais bien aller
surprise ce soir je vous vois surpris
mais thierry ardisson a été pris d'une
légère à disposition passagère et comme
dirait sabatier thierry je sais que tu
nous regarder nous te regarde on nous
regarde et on a pu atterrir 10 ans qui
sera bientôt qu'un des siens tandis que
ce soir que je connais particulièrement
bien qui est pétri de qualités qui est
merveilleux beau sensible doux 1 prévoir
c'est le merveilleux le merveilleux
patrick sébastien
il fait un malheur confortable un lien
est bien là ah je suis bien bon alors je
voulais venir
ouais j'étais je regarde ça tous les
mercredis soirs
non je te jure c'est pas parce que c'est
toi on va passer une sacrée soir c'est
pas parce que c'est mais tu adores
christophe ouais ça me fait plaisir que
tu sois là tu sais sabatier voilà on va
faire une petite interview vous
tu connais les missions que je balance
non tu balances pas comme d'habitude tu
es gentil que tout le monde doit toute
façon moi j'aime tout le monde à thème
tout le monde c'est vrai on oui c'est
vrai qu'on me croit pas mais non mais on
va voir si j'admets que j'aime pas du
tir au pigeon
alors on commence simplement drucker
drucker j'ai vu dans le zénith denisot
michel drucker disait est ce que ça
allait pas quittée sur antenne 2 drucker
et ils disaient oui est ce que c'est
vrai patrie que tu as demandé a pu être
le samedi parce que ça t'embête d'être
en face de moi et toi tu disais oui
absolument j'ai demandé ouais ça
m'embête libres 2 oui au programme de
variétés à la limite je préfère la
concurrence qui aujourd'hui l'autre soir
au resto au concert des restos du coeur
à l'opéra ouais je sais pas si tf1 ne
diffusera lundi prochain dans tous les
cas tu as dit en parlant de michel
drucker
si le soir de mai qui lui met un copieur
avec où ils demandent si tu t'es pas
fait mal aux pieds ouais et envoie
beaucoup de choses sur le monde
quoi parce que parce que c'est vrai que
ce mec est gentil ouais et c'est alors
en plus il ya des gens qui vont encore
mal tourner sans nom auparavant j'avais
du mal aux yeux du manager voilà j'ai
fait j'ai fait rire oui c'est ce que je
voulais vous a beaucoup je parle de
sabatier en parlant de collaborateurs
machette ou ça aucune incidence s'est
déjà bâti et a dit lui c'est la milice
là c'est donc sur un jeu de mots oui
l'ami l apostrophe a fait de la pub pour
vichy voilà et puis tous et tous ses
assistants il appelle collaborateurs la
sfl avis de recherche
bah c'est une jeu de la vérité voilà et
c'est ce que je me suis aperçu qu'il y
avait une alliance entre nous servent
rôle mais ça rien à voir c'est passé par
le collaborateur je vais dès que tu dis
un truc c'est interprété non ppda le peu
d un ouais on sait bien à tulle m
ah ouais ouais ouais ah non mais c'est
vrai non moi je prends pas position
j'ai eu dès qu'est ce que je peux pas te
dire j'ai eu très peu de contacts avec
lui ouais j'ai j'ai eu ma fille il a
fait l'émission est venu faire léo ferré
on a pas mal de points communs
ouais il a été papa très tôt aux six
mois est lui aussi savait 15 ans je
crois et non à ben je veux dire c'est
quelqu'un de chez on n'a pas parlé de
pierre carles non plus quelqu'un qui a
été viré de tf1 parce qu'il a ouvert sa
gueule ça arrive aussi
et le problème c'est que maintenant
pierre carles s'intéresse à ppda
studieux ah bon ouais tu vas voir le
magazine du fonds
c'était le 16 décembre dernier le
lendemain du retour de patrick poivre
d'arvor de cuba et en cet instant au
moment où il passe à l'écran la pipe il
ya n'avait pas encore annoncé de contre
vérités au sujet de l'interview de fidel
castro
donc il n'avait pas encore donné dans
l'intox mais écoutez bien ce qu'il va
dire
fidel castro et 7 sortir de son
isolement économique mais n'est pas prêt
à aucun renoncement idéologique l'une
des équipes de terrain l'a interrogé
hier à cuba intox
voilà maintenant on peut dire que c'est
de l'intox car voici à présent la
soi-disant interview de fidel castro par
l'équipe de tf1 telle qu'elle a été
diffusée dans le journal de 20h observez
bien attentivement ces images
un jour viendra le président jusqu alors
la devise de cuba c'était le socialisme
ou la mort est-ce que ça va pas devenir
le capitalisme ou la mort en fait castro
ne s'adresse pas là à ppda et ppda ne
lui a jamais posé cette question c'est
une supercherie et c'est elle cette
journaliste argentine qui a en réalité
posé la question à castro
comme on le voit dans la version
intégrale de la conférence de presse
filmée par la télévision cubaine
adhap et ali talât salaces à découvrir
social est mort - de théo capital et
voilà filet castro répond bien là la
question qui lui était posée mais
réécoutons le répondre à cette même
question sur tf1 jusqu alors la devise
de cuba c'était le socialisme ou la mort
est ce que ça va pas devenir le
capitalisme ou la mort conditionner le
monde doit poil alors là vous l'avez
entendu fidel castro ne répond plus non
le socialisme ou la mort comme dans la
version originale
et revoici la journaliste argentine qui
a posé la question à castro ppda est
juste derrière elle au deuxième plan à
droite sur l'écran
c'était donc quelques minutes avant
qu'il ne lui subtilise sa question puis
truc la réponse de castro alors je vais
interroger il ya un peu plus d'un an
ppda au sujet de ces pratiques
journalistiques et notamment les
questions refaite après coup alors là ça
c'est un problème que j'ai c'est de
d'éviter je trouve ça très très mauvais
sont les questions qui sont faites après
parce que d'abord
elles peuvent être fausses je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec vous les questions
réécrites ou refaites c'est pas bien
compliqué un peu une triche
hindrichs voilà c'est de la triche c'est
lui qu'il dise qu'il a fait avec fidel
castro on peut d'ailleurs sans revoir un
extrait qu'est ce que vous diriez à la
télévision française pour essayer de
défendre ce régime
qu'est ce que vous diriez à la
télévision française
vous avez bien entendu castro ne répond
évidemment pas à cette question dans la
version originale de la conférence de
presse puisqu'ils ne s'adressait pas à
la télévision française mais vous allez
le découvrir voilà c'est en réalité à
cette correspondante d'une radio
argentine qu'il répondait juste avant la
base du métier c'est l'honnêteté
on sait déjà que c'est pas l'objectivité
c'est moi la netteté dans ppda se
trouvait en compagnie de régis faucon à
cuba filmé ici juste avant la conférence
de presse de castro par un cameraman
d'une chaîne de télévision hollandaise
vendeurs de saucisses iam ces lignes
en fait il n'est pas si loin que ça de
la vérité faucon a lui aussi ceci sonne
et les propos de castro écoutez est-ce
que vous n'éprouvez pas un formidable
sentiment d'isolement
il faut résister on va le magazine
télérama qui a le premier dévoilé la
supercherie dans cet article paru le 2
janvier dernier suite à quoi
ppda a envoyé un droit de réponse dans
lequel on peut lire notamment
c'est ainsi que nous avons pu approcher
filiale castro et lui poser au cours
d'une conférence de presse quelques
questions qui semblent l'avoir irrité
c'est complètement faux à la fin de la
conférence de presse ppda et son équipe
n'avait posé aucune question à fidel
castro cloud yanhai souvenez-vous se
trouvait juste devant ppda il faut qu'on
elle était dernièrement de passage à
paris
et voici la scène que vient de décrire
claudio fidel castro a fini de répondre
aux questions
alors on ne verra pas sur ces images
l'équipe de tf1 mais on va entendre la
seule question qui est en définitive
poser à castro pour la télévision
française
mais castro est reparti alors avoir
adressé la parole
entouré de ses conseillers de ses gardes
du corps des pda et régis faucon ensuite
enregistrer leurs vraies fausses
questions faisant comme si castro les
écouter ils n'écoutaient pas voilà la
vérité par un truc comme ça je pense que
ppda doit réagir normalement et que il a
déjà réagi en écrivant à télérama lé
canard enchaîné en a parlé et il est le
bien le mal qu'elle ans il est le
bienvenu ici pour s'expliquer
l'autre quart temps s'il vous plaît pas
de carton je suis ce mail nationalité
des démissions oui c'est ça et moi je
suis à ce décès c'est un carton parler
soyez sympa irradie son qui m'attend
j'ai une sorte de répétition et ce n'est
pas tout je pense pas écoute vieux même
si tu ressembles un peu et smaïn les
sosies on les recevait hier
alors maintenant tu me lâches attenti
non je vais me fâcher très fort et après
tu ressemblera plus jamais à personne au
prêt à temps le nez un calme toi y'a pas
de problème on passera à chier on va
discuter il n'y a aucun problème à
trouver une solution n'est pas trouvée
tu connais le montage et mot de passe il
ya un mot de passe tu connais pas ma
tasse mardi sont montés ou toi
[Musique]
la raison
alors pas ton boulot c'est comique quoi
de dire ça c'est vrai on apprend comique
non monsieur comique tout de suite on a
l'impression que ça fait moins rire
voilà c'est ça ma fait moi voilà c'est
ça la taille comme banon mais justement
les faits malgré le sérieux d'un de quoi
se marrer
ouais non non bon alors ça ça coûte trop
cher maintenant
et on voit que ça marche et c'est vrai
que dans ses premiers boulots à essayer
des êtres documentaliste à minutes
bah oui c'est à dire que j'avais j'avais
16 ans chercher du boulot et puis j'ai
vu un jour dans le journal
une annonce on cherchait un aide
documentaliste et donc c'était minutes
je me suis pointé fauchois francs ils
ont été extrêmement sympa avec moi mais
mon regardé bizarrement quoi quand
j'étais donc reçu par le biais du
personnel il m'a fait comprendre
évidemment que bon c'était pas possible
et tout et je suis parti déçus et puis
10 ans 15 ans après j'ai appris qu'un
d'accord et alors scoop soit 1,10
couperet
quand j'ai annoncé sa non j'ai écrit un
bouquin où il a annoncé le directeur de
minute mike leigh non il m'a même offert
et maintenant c'est d'ailleurs c'est
quoi c'est bizarre et contradictoires et
maintenant on va faire de la possibilité
d'écrire dans le journal minute devine
ce que j'ai répondu est ce que tu crois
que tu pourrais faire rire le pen je
sais pas je pense que certainement se
veut nomade voir certainement du bourg
je pense mais bon je crois que tu ferais
quoi pour le faire tuer des ébats écoute
je vais dire franchement puisque nous
rentrons dans les confidences
un jour j'ai pris l'avion à nice avec
jean marie le pen devant moi je t'assure
et julienne j'ai mis les mains
extrêmement moite et c'est la première
fois de ma vie que j'avais envie que
l'avion s'écrase je pouvais pas à jeter
dedans
je suis dis pas ça parce que je suis un
homme public extra mais comme ça pour
des bizarreries personnel c'est un
bonhomme gérant des rencontres et tu
connais stéphane monaco j'ai croisé un
jour où ben ouais effectivement aller
assez mignonne mais bon tu sais un
problème s'il faut lui demander sa main
ouais mais bon c'est marrant mais voilà
ça brille ça pis tu vois ma condition
sociale c'est pas évident en quoi ils
croient pas un ange y croit pas ils
croient pas du 6e qui comptent pas plus
toi tu sais quel pas sa famille
viendrait de constantine comme toi as tu
crois ouais amérique choses à faire on
va voir
[Musique]
ouf le 26 juin 1989 le prince rainier de
monaco fêter ses 40 ans de règne
ouf car ce sont quarante années sauvé in
extremis pour perpétuer le nom des
grimaldi vieille de 700 ans
une prolongation qui doivent tous
écoutez bien à une vulgaire lingère de
constantine l'histoire se passe en 1890
en algérie louis 2 le grand-père de
renier y est officier la blanchisseuse
de la caserne ne lui plaît beaucoup
une petite fille charlotte naîtra de ce
méga fait banal mais l'histoire ne
s'arrête pas là en 1918 on a signé un
traité entre monaco et la france
la france reconnaissait la souveraineté
de monaco est exigée par une clause
dynastique à ce que si jamais le trône
restés vacants et bien la principauté
passé devenez protectorat français
administrée par les alpes maritimes
or en 1920 la lignée des grimaldi
n'avait plus d'héritier pour garder son
rocher à 50 ans louis ii avait oublié de
se marier
tant pis la fille de la lingère ferait
la faire et on l'a marié on a arrangé un
mariage avec le descendant d'une des
plus illustres familles françaises
les polignac et pierre conte de polignac
a épousé en 1920 la petite princesse
charlotte charlotte souvet ainsi la
principauté de tempérament excentrique
volcanique mal à l'aise sur le rocher
charlotte se montrera pourtant bonne
fille en 1944 elle abdiquera de ses
droits au trône en faveur de l'un de ses
deux enfants
régnier
le feuilleton des grimaldi pouvait
continuer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le traité de 1918 est
toujours en vigueur mais une question se
pose
albert aura-t-il des enfants ou
faudra-t-il trouver d'autres héritiers
pas très loin cette fois ci
[Musique]
alors les grimaldi descente il d'une
lingère de constantine d'abord j'ai
demandé à ce mail à l'oreille alors pour
vous laisser le temps de réfléchir à
tous les deux et pour laisser aux gens
le temps de jouer chez eux et de
s'engueuler qu'est-ce qu'on écoute corti
dans l'autre le petit père du québec qui
sont habituelles donné beaucoup de
talent pour une fois c'est par roch
voisine et luc de larochellière robot à
ce titre
[Musique]
être star mais personne ne veut être une
planète
tout le monde un an et
au personnel
et m
venir
personne
il fait beau
en train
mais personne
personne ps
[Musique]
à c
chaque
ayrault
m
personnel
psa
bensen vs
non
[Musique]
szavay
le seuil
mais monaco descente il d'une ingère de
constantine mylan de l'afo de l'intox
sans hésitation de l'intox de l'intox
étoiles avides de l'intox ainsi possible
ah bon ouais sommes pas trop loin
moi je peux le révéler maintenant tu
m'as dit que c'était de l'intox c'est
assez amusant ma présence ici les à
constantine savoir quels sujets relation
est constante et je pense qu'on a fait
exprès éventuellement bon ben on va
savoir on va écouter l'expert à toi
phillip et bien qu un tonnerre
d'applaudissements se passe entendre
jusqu'au rocher de monaco c'est de
l'info à
attends attends mais vous êtes du même
péché par alors j'ai des chances alors
mais tu as toutes les chances c'est pour
ça qu'on a fait ça mais oui elles sont
partout les caméras stéphanie accès au
moteur du jeu
un roman
et
bonsoir mano bienvenue aux folies
bergères pour l'émission ne pas pas
maintenant tu sais ce qu'il ya ce soir
l'émission le pape a mano ya zorro le
vrai zorro à la zorro c'est celui qui a
le chapeau c'est celui qui a le masque
c'est celui que les petites moustaches
et puis à le sergent garcia
tu es content de voir le sergent garcia
je sais qui c'est l'invité je sais qui
c'est l'invité ce soit sidwaya doter la
partie
on se croirait à bercy non stockholm
tout cas mordoré tu es bon soir est-ce
que tu tiens compte des attaques dont
les programmes sont victimes au sujet de
la violence
oui bien sûr elles qui étaient remis
depuis longtemps c'est pourquoi
maintenant plus personne n'ose rien dire
tout le monde a baissé les bras les
parents baisser les bras non parce que
si c'est pas violent et toujours été
mais par exemple on va lui dis toujours
que tu montres effectivement enfin les
séries sont montrés des psychologues
bon c'est vrai tout est visionnée par
des psychologues et voulait jamais des
noms des psychologues banon pourquoi bon
je pense que ça change
mais c'est vraiment vu par des
psychologues vraiment vu ses il ya un
rôle de psychologue avec un responsable
la tête et tout et tout est vérifié si
un épisode qui qui peut éventuellement
poser des problèmes en disant vous avez
les abcès j'ai eu affaire ségolène royal
qui ségolène royal c'est une dame qui
écrase il s'appelle le ras-le-bol des
bébés a peur où elle disait que c'était
pas bien que les enfants regardent
dorothée tout ça tu t'en souviens de
cinq ans même mission et puis tu sais ce
qui s'est passé quand même on en a déjà
parlé un jour il y avait une émission de
dorothée du club dorothée et via vais
ariane et corbier qui vidait une
poubelle comme ça il y avait un livre de
ségolène royal 2 l'an je crois que c'est
bien de se servir la télévision pour
répondre aux gens qui vous ont attaqué
titre michelin c'est pas méchant on a
montré solide à l'antenne ça fait 38 ah
bon donc tu crois qu'elle était contente
quand le csa a modifié les quotas de
séries japonaises
tu te souviens de ce moment là tu as
demandé aux jeunes téléspectateurs
d'écrire au csa non attendez que je
prends toujours le public pour des gens
responsables quel que soit leur âge je
leur ai expliqué pourquoi le mercredi
après midi qui était devenu une heure de
grande écoute donc des programmes
français et européens on avait changé la
programmation des émissions et je leur
ai dit que le csa avait décidé
teradata et si vous devez leur écrire
point c'est tout je n'ai jamais c'est ce
qu'ils ont dit tu veux la réponse tandis
qu'ils avaient reçu une lettre d'un prof
et d'une classe qui demandait qu'on
supprime justement les séries japonaises
pas beaucoup une lettre quand même comme
quoi c'est pour les embêter que tu les
avait appelés conseil nancy de
surveillance de l'audiovisuel période de
l'audiovisuel ces trophées s'adapter
c'est pas pour les embêter tout mais le
plus grave quand il ya eu la sphère des
insignes nazis sur les uniformes
c'est pas si une asie c'est ce signe est
un ski prend un signe de vie à l'envers
c'est un vrai cycle du judo ouais vous
demande pas de données de deux d'arts
martiaux
ouais c'était très très bien qu'ils
existent et japonais avait mis cela sur
un uniforme dans un dessin animé
japonais
mais c'est vrai que les nazis mais vous
avez dit quand on enfin je dis vous
parce que c'est pas tout seul bien
aujourd'hui lady mond n'avait pas eu le
temps de visionner toute la série c'est
à dire que les séries qui parce qu'ils
sont pas entièrement visionner à
l'époque
et puis aussi mais ça c'est bon il a
fait un rabbin des voix aussi j'ai fait
beaucoup de vent de scandale
oui ça va gratuit il fait pas et des
gens qu'on dit que c'était antisémite
d'appeler une fuite chez un personnage
s'appelle robin des bois temps c'était
jacky jacky jacubowicz ouais tu avais
l'auteur qui était quand même
j'ai fait également le producteur
également s'était désisté la sortie du
film robin des bois jacky est déguisé en
rabaska rabat des bois je veux dire
c'est de l'humour de baffie c'est pas
vraiment très méchant alors tu m'as
mettre à jour mais non parce que tu vas
même enchaînement sur un costard de
staercke baffie a fait sur toi aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe je crois que tu va avoir
besoin de beaucoup d'humour auprès
costard de stars
tenez vous aimez dorothée tiens vous me
réglez madame s'il vous plaît pour
régler quoi que dise que c'est 30 francs
monsieur mais je ne vous ai rien demandé
non mais je sais bien c'est dorothée qui
a mis cette technique de vente au point
c'est de la vente directe et alors alors
on donnait dispose enfants il part en le
taillant suis qu'à ma chérie tu aimes
dorothée que c'est pour toi
ces 30 francs madame cdh avant le direct
a maintenant mais pas le droit de
reprendre le disque à l'enfant dorothée
m'interdit de reprendre des disques j'ai
donné un énorme alors là mais c'est
dorothée bal avec abyss et techniques au
moins 30 bretelle est pas petit c'est ce
qu'elle fait c'est dorothée camion alors
c'est de retenir comme ça aux gens on
les met à main puis à dire après ces
trente francs mais c'est de recommencer
à dire c'est 30 francs on va merci hein
c'est pour moi vous me le donner oui
c'est une vente directe et dorothée
camus cette vente au point pour se faire
des couilles en or c'est obligé vous
l'avez tous chez madame j'ai pas de
monnaie je vous en donne 3g pas de
monnaie alors je vous donne un club
dorothée je veux te collonges et un
pin's 1 j'ai un vibromasseur
qu'est ce que je vais le stérilet
dorothée qui va le sortir vous voulez
quoi qu'est ce que vous voulez aller
jouer sur l'autoroute les enfants
malades
dorothée n'aime pas les enfants alors
foutez lui la paix à dorothée 1 tiens
c'est pour vous voilà non c'est 30
francs madame vous me réglez s'il vous
plaît j'ai pas loin de reprendre madame
dorothée m'interdit de reprendre les
disques que je donne aux enfants c'est
pas bon pour son image
c'est dorothée qui a mis cette technique
aux points tiens ma chérie il confie sa
maman dont vous êtes les chante avec vos
enfants
tu es mon chéri c'est pour toi j'ai pas
mal de reprendre vous vous pouvez me
régler s'il vous plaît mais
plaignez-vous à dorothée si vous n'êtes
pas contente
regardez vous laisser aller la faire
pleurer mais j'allais rentrer enfants
malheureux de ce principe mais c'est
dorothée qui a mis cette fois ci c'est
débile en plus rappelle que ça rapporte
du pognon c'est ça le principal
elle est à déplorer c'est moi qui te
lofteuse hop je le paierai de ma poche
m
alors non je vais te dire la vérité mais
de dire la vérité je pensais à la suite
de cette séquence te demander de venir
s'excuser mais je pense que la réaction
de dorothée était quand même beaucoup
plus drôle et malin juin début
d'érection va
bravo doigté dit je me mouille pas dans
les sujets sans compter la main je crois
que dorothée eu la bonne réaction
c'est vrai oui on applaudit dorothée
c'est connaître que c'est bien fait ça
va la même application
je l'avais dit elle a des couilles bon
et bien voilà maintenant mais ça va
maintenant tu es ça va il est plus mou
victoire non je suis très mouillé on
peut pas
mal fini ça va lolo les fastes où les
bleus qui est le doter les meilleures
affaires
voilà c'est pas à toi fais un noir à
excuse bois autant pour moitié au temps
pour moi pour jouer avec tout ce soir
deux stars qui ont touché le fond le
plus connu des français le plus célèbre
des vingt mille lieues sous les mers
pourtant toujours au creux de la vague
le commandant cousteau non refroidis là
je parle parce que tout à l'heure sont
en fait moins bien que présentes
cousteau battre et naulleau mais je suis
d'accord mais là je suis en train de me
refroidir donc si je pouvais parler tout
de suite ça m'arrange
face à lui le réalisateur du grand bleu
dans la vie comme au cinéma il a pris de
la bouteille c'est sans doute pour ça
qu'ils manquent pas d'air luc besson
combien de temps que tu rester en apnée
bah je sais pas on va voir comment dans
vous gaver d'habitude d'approcher les
fuck
quel est votre plus grand souvenir c'est
quand j'ai fait le divan d'henri chapier
mais avec l'âge je vais pas peur d'être
un peu largué dans maintenant on
plaisantait pas plus branché chez moi
vous aimez les histoires serré
commandant oui surtout quand il s'agit
de ré de mourut ne soyez pas rect
invité ce soir les grands moyens vont
moins bien mais qu'est ce que tu veux
que je te vendent personne te connais tu
es gentil
personne ne me connaît banon va faire
alors tu es gentil avant toi le
connaissez tous il s'appelle patrick
timsit il est dos son spectacle est
merveilleux acheter son disque il est
hier à vos soirées d'hiver je veux
demande d'accueil ma vie
si le move est plus lourd aux oies et
donc c'est comme le tir au pigeon
d'argile monsieur je vais te jeter des
noms et je crois pas que j'en ai
suffisamment pas d'anciens florent pagny
florent pagny way aerial on est qu'il se
plaignait que bree bruel lui a tout
piqué et je disais il ya peut-être un
truc à piquer à florent pagny c'est son
micro non mais c'est du tir au pigeon
d'argile et je les aime tous et comme
manuel alors même que le monde
ouais pourquoi tu dis google attention
c'est un nouveau philosophe
ah bon ah oui nos jeunes a fait quoi non
mais tu vois la vie est courte
ce sont les journées qui sont langues ça
c'est diderot merci beaucoup d'être venu
beaucoup je vous aime beaucoup ça c'est
patrick bruel à à pierre bachelet away
jean pierre bachelet je laime en tant
que l'imitateur dieu qu'est ce qui
m'amuse continue jacques brel je veux
dire non mais c'est vrai nom mais son
métier c'est comique ma jédir spectacle
d'émotion tu sors du spectacle si on
regarde ce que tu as payé tu pleures
jeudi michel leeb
alors c'est celui que je préfère à ta
raison m'en parler michel leeb je laime
parce que jerry lewis lui a tout piqué
quoi puis michel leeb problème quand il
imite le noir quelle finesse [ __ ] qui
passe du noir au sein du centre noir et
une chez les bills unique tant mieux
sur la taille qu'elle vénère stefan
gimpl échos non c'était fanny monaco
c'est vrai les eu un problème parce que
son père a toujours cru qu'elle faisait
du cinéma parce qu ils croyaient que le
césar qui était posée sur la cheminée
il n'a pas compris que c'était ce qui
restait de la voiture de la princesse
grace mercy monaco aura géré ailleurs
maintenant michel petrucciani à michel
petrucciani
alors là attention moi je dis monsieur
monsieur petruccelli attention non non
parce que c'est trop facile de déconner
on pourra dire ouais qui sait ce mec là
la première fois j'ai vu arriver je
crois que c'est un césar non moi je dis
myopathe myopathe
oui mais petrucci
simone signoret ça c'est les
intouchables
ouais ouais intouchable même yves
montand sur la fin les touches et plus
sébastien patrick sébastien non mais non
mais moi je même quand il fait ses
imitations
attention attention je vais vous faire
une imitation attention c'est un petit
peu difficile je vais vous imiter le
maire de paris et vous allez devinez qui
c'est attention si vous n'êtes que
chirac l'as rome c'est qui
[Musique]
si tu peux dans la rue toujours n'y a
pas de problème bah écoute le pto que
j'aurais pas croiser des mecs comme toi
je sortait tranquillement
maintenant je vais me méfier sophie
marceau 7 sur cette formidable
ah non mais leurs alliés des trucs
incroyables ah non mais moi j'ai appris
des trucs sur moi j'ai eu deux grands
chocs intellectuelle dans ma vie
nietzsche ouais et sophie marceau elle
aura dire les politiciens c'est tous des
menteurs
la guerre c'est pas bon la maladie c'est
bien du malheur les cheveux sur la tête
ça bouge dans mr sa réponse
pour andré lamy j'étais sûr qu'il durait
plus longtemps que le luron parce que
hélas pas tellement plus de talent mais
il a tellement plus d'anticorps
il faut brancher médicaments non ouais
ouais je suis branché médicaments parce
que c'est vrai que ça fait partie de la
vie quoi je suis un consommateur un un
peu trop non c'est ce qu'on me dit mais
quand est persuadé d'être malade faut
que tu te soignes way pour et essayez
pas là chrome au pâtis à chrome os pâtit
tu vas voir ce que c'est ah oui je veux
bien tuer c'est vrai si ça me plaisait
oui je suis client et bars garde alors
alors via chrome os pâtit mesdames
messieurs orange
glu vert rouge les couleurs aux dires de
leurs adeptes soigneux la plupart des
maladies courantes après la naturopathie
la musicothérapie et l'iridologie voici
la chromothérapie mise au point par un
neuropsychiatre reconverti dans la
culture le docteur christian agra parts
cette nouvelle médecine énergétique se
pratique à l'aide d'un simple
projecteurs de lumière de cette lampe
halogène par des fibres optiques et au
bout des fibres optiques
nous avons des filtres qui sélectionne
les longueurs d'onde qui nous intéresse
on parle de couleur pour simplifier les
choses mais en fait ce sont des
longueurs d'onde bien précises qui ont
des effets thérapeutiques
j'étais brûlé ici donc j'avais une
grosse bride ici au dessus de la lèvre
supérieure et ici sous le front j'avais
une bride qui était assez conséquente et
depuis le 17 juin le dr agrapart tu as
commencé son traitement
j'étais un peu sceptique parce que bon
moi j'avais ce carcan aux permanences
donc quand il m'a dit pas maintenant
vous ne portez plus pour moi ça est une
délivrance qui a qu'un viennent se
brûler on dit que c'est une pénétration
de l'énergie chaleur et nous allons donc
appelé pour soigner cette dame de
l'énergie froide
il suffira que nous utilisions la
couleur orange ou la longueur d'onde
correspondant à la couleur orange pour
qu'il y ait toujours une réponse froide
de l'organisme le range provoque
toujours au niveau d'organismes une
réponse froide le vert provoque toujours
au niveau de l'organisme une réponse
sécheresse et le bleu provoque toujours
au niveau de l'organisme
une réponse humidité il suffit de penser
à naître mal à dépenser la lumière bleue
cette lumière bleue pâle que l'on voit
dans un prisme et si vous projetez cette
lumière bleue sur une personne qui est
malade ou la soigner instinctivement on
appelle ça le manteau bleu de la vierge
c'est une lumière qui soit une
terriblement
je suis très reconnaissante au docteur
agrapart je dis que c'est un miracle
c'est un conte de fées 1
pour soigner par les couleurs s de
l'info est de l'intox
patrick timsit à l'oreille
alors l'institut pour soigner par les
couleurs s de l'info est de la taxe
pendant que vous réfléchissez chez vous
que luc besson et commandant cousteau
font pareil qu'est ce que les coûts de
corti du créateur dédie à mon gsm pti
s'appelle umberto tozzi moitié est la
triche pas
on
[Musique]
non ça thomas y prodigue aussi elle
avait relégué fossé près solo d'eddie
quand y'a du cnml paire phare est la
città qu'on y avait jean c'était
surprenant sommet commerciaux des
pointes d'or c
bien sûr
coc
pas sûr
un johnny poteau que metz est coquine
évoqué l'amour
oooh
oh
[Musique]
on va
non
sauf une idée à la con
des centaines tonneaux
magna
arrêtée là
guaino à peine si bien
soigné par les couleurs s de l'info est
de l'intox c'est à toi de jouer cette
fois intox atteint soit pourquoi tu
crois pas un coup de rancho brûlures
dans terminator 3 professeurs agrapart
touati mme babin pas vraiment le même
nom
intox intox et vous comment dans le
point sur ce qu'il faut mais ne finiront
jamais nous est soumis toujours nouvelle
star je me suis allongé marin tu vas pas
du tout tu m'as dit autre chose tout à
l'heure c'était le service public on
peut pas tricher
d'accord mais présenté comme les
allemandes et 13 passes et remonter
comme les hommes et non bâti bonnet
d'âne non triomphe pour philippe pierre
invasive officiers et oui et oui
triomphe tu me dis si je suis trop court
oyo fait ça va c'est bon
triomphe quand on a fait le grand bleu
on peut se planter avec les couleurs
puisque c'était de linfo re
messieurs bonsoir bienvenue aussi qui
dans
bon jouer avec nous ce soir anthony
delon
[Applaudissements]
ok vous la barre doit arriver quel est
votre profession matt nageurs et
nageuses votre dieu landaise ouais enfin
bon ce soir est la forme ouais cassel
et votre profession comédienne vous avez
un violon de ping pong
même à dix centimètres du champignon
attention attention
premier indice non je vous rappellerai
ils ont rêvé trouver l'invité de ce soir
premier indice notre invité a longtemps
fait un duo avec un autre comique
deuxième indice notre invité vient de
sortir un disque de mal jusqu'à nos
troisièmes avis
notre invité joue dans le feuilleton le
plus célèbre factures non 90 j'espère
que vous allez trouver notre invité
n'est toujours pas déçus du socialisme
reparti bon soir bonsoir rue à double
jeu
j'ai eu 16 en 1939 1 comment tu as vécu
cette époque comment tu es ce que tu
faisais est-ce que tu étais conscient
des dangers qui s'accumulaient comme ça
où sont les premières à n'est pas
tellement c'est à dire que bon j'étais
très jeune
et puis quand on est jeune on se rend
pas bien compte des dangers mais à
partir de 1942
la peur a commencé à s'installer pour
beaucoup de jeunes
d'abord j'ai vu plein de copains juifs
partir ne jamais revenir et j'ai vu
d'autres qui se cachaient qu'ils étaient
obligés de se cacher puis ça m'est
arrivé aussi
donc j'ai vécu mal c'était a
l'impression qu'on m'a volé ma jeunesse
les années qui sont les plus belles de
saison à 20 ans c'est dur a été terrible
il a la défaite l'arrivée de pétain tu
ça se passe et comment c'était quels
souvenirs tu en as comme ça j'ai
souvenir terrible des rues de paris
complètement déserte et et des allemands
qui marchaient dans les rues au pas de
l'oie descendant les champs elysées
c'est quand même malgré tout même si on
n'est pas très patriote saison tu penses
pas tellement ces choses là tout j'avais
l'impression de deux contraintes et
effrayante mais j'ai vu des tas de
choses très dures
je tiens pas à parler d'ailleurs
et je souhaite surtout que personne n'en
voit jamais ça quand tu quand tu dis
j'avais des amis juifs qui étaient en
ont mené en allemagne vous saviez ce qui
se passait non ça lui faut être honnête
on savait qu'ils partent et c'est
seulement à partir de du moment où les
américains ont pénétré sur le territoire
sur le territoire allemand qu'on a on a
su les voies horreur on le on ne savait
pas à paris on ne savait pas il avait
disparu mais personne ne savait ce
qu'était vraiment les horreurs du camp
maintenant je vais te demander quelque
chose tu vas me laisser là tu vas te
diriger vers le fauteuil qui est là bas
ouais tu verras écrit la question sur le
fauteuil et quand tu vas t'asseoir sur
le fauteuil le fauteuil va te poser la
question ah bon dallas tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
jean marc thibault est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous aimez les allemands comme n'importe
quel autre peuple
et oui je voudrais mais je peux quand
même pas arriver à oublier tout
quelque 200 résistants salue aussi des
amis collabos non j'en ai pas connu
beaucoup mais finalement je le temps
venu bon ceux qui n'ont pas commis de
vrais crimes
je comprends qu'ils aient été entraînés
c'était très difficile de choisir à une
certaine époque à partir de 42 ans on
pouvait plus lutter mais avant 43 48 42
je comprends que des gens puissent être
trompés
tu as eu 20 ans en 43 est ce que tu te
souviens de cet anniversaire la non
celui 43 noms mais celui de 44 oui oui
parce que je suis né le 24 ou 1 et à 11
heures du soir
le jour de mon anniversaire toutes les
cloches de paris ont sonné
de clercq venait d'entrer dans la
capitale tu as vécu la libération comme
ça oui
après la guerre tu as été tentée comme
beaucoup de gens à l'époque par le
communisme n'ont jamais vraiment j'ai
très vite senti que tu y avait quelque
chose derrière d'abord j'ai rencontré
dans le maquis beaucoup de communistes
qui étaient les gens extrêmement
courageux extrêmement discipliné mais
qui peut-être et était trop disciplinés
et moi ça me faisait peur j'ai peur des
gens des gens trop bien va-t-il et j'ai
senti assez vite alors qu'on savait
encore rien sur le stalinisme
j'ai senti que c'était quand même parce
qu'il y avait mieux
ouais et il faut quand même que les gens
aient beaucoup de liberté pour qu'il
soit on n'impose pas un bonheur de fort
avec des armes et ne s'est jamais été
tentée par sa non et tu t'es déjà
socialistes s'étaient déjà de gauche à
cette époque
oui je vais te dire c'est une tradition
dans la famille alors
le mandat respect pour je le serai
simplement par respect pour mes mes
parents mes arrière grands parents je
sais que on était socialiste et de
gauche depuis 1848 dans ma famille une
tradition une tradition tu admires et de
gaulle à une époque
oui à la libération mais envoyé était à
l'époque de l'algérie tu penses qu'il a
réglé le problème il a réglé un peu vite
à mon avis c'est à dire que je pense que
je pense pas dupe je pense qu'il fallait
trouver une solution qui permette à deux
peuples de vivre ensemble en commis
vivent elles finalement assez bien et
mitterrand tu admirais oui tu vas de mai
encore oui tu juges comment la politique
qui a été menée depuis 1981 ben je pense
que l est elle correspond c'est parce
que on on pense que c'est un échec sans
doute c'est un échec mais c'est un échec
mondiale et le discrédit dont sont
victimes aujourd'hui les hommes
politiques la crise du parlementarisme
est-ce que c'est inquiète ça m'inquiète
parce que ça peut profiter à des gens
qui ont fui en ce sens de la démocratie
oui c'est ça qui est dangereux sinon
bon ils ont peut-être un peu cherché les
hommes politiques osent ils ont
peut-être pas sont peut-être pas mis au
goût du jour
j'étends montrer des hommes politiques
la cie va voir noranda fille
[Musique]
une question présentez-vous bernhard
schreier député des yvelines
de quel groupe vous êtes du groupe
socialiste c'est heavy metal pendante un
bon groupe mais pourquoi pas vous êtes
débuté depuis combien de temps dix ans
est-ce que c'est plus facile quand on
est député pour se tirer des conseils
c'est ce que ça aide
ça je pense que cela dépende pas du rôle
de
et de la profession que l'on fait quand
on est député est ce que c'est plus
facile avec les gonzesses après pour
conclure écoutez ce n'est pas une
question sérieuse posée une question sur
la fin il faut que pourrait-on question
pour moi sérieuse parce que des fois on
est sur un coup on est sur le on est à
deux doigts de nick et elana se casse
mais je comprends pas du tout sont
parfois il est là qui sont impressionnés
d'aynac on n'aurait pas pensé me retirer
mais comme on le député hop on peut leur
mettre une carte au jeu c'est une
plaisanterie
non c'est une vraie question messieurs
juste une question vous vous teniez la
main ce qu'il y a des relations
homosexuelles
parmi les hommes politiques des rapports
ou ce n'est pas la main d'abord si vous
êtes caresser un petit peu vous avez eu
un début d'érection je vous avez une
question jean-pierre quand on est connu
c'est plus facile avec les gonzesses
mais c'est plus difficile si forcément
plus difficile baisse kilomètres des
lunettes noires
raymond une question quand on est un
homme politique est ce que c'est plus
facile avec les gonzesses après sata et
des toits dans les centres d'abord
d'abord pourquoi me tutoyez alors est-ce
que je t'aime bien bon vous devrez
sympathique on a pas on n'a pas vécu
ensemble comme ça parce que j'ai pas
voulu
il est temps semble donc je suis là par
ailleurs le député maire de pau et vous
avez payé d'attouchements sexuels avec
j'adore yvette et je crois que ça vaut
mieux la doré que tout le reste que les
bones ou l'homme yvette j'étais pas
jacques simplement est ce que le fait
d'être connu en politique ça sert avec
les conseils c'est à dire que depuis que
j'ai rencontré ma femme qui est
fantastique
alors les gonzesses ne me concerne plus
plu du tout tu t'es fait coupé par un
veto vaut pas du tout
on se tutoie pas alors un bien on se
vouvoie pas voilà dit on ne parle pas
chez ben voilà pas rock'n'roll 1
tous les langues de bois mais à les
entendre ils s'en servent jamais ouais
en tous les cas pour son deuxième voyage
la chambre des députés c'est encore
mieux que le premier je propose qu'on
l'applaudisse ce qu'elle vaut la liberté
quand même nom wii ware faire ça à la
télévision d'un web en finale et je
crois que quand même nom mais il faut
alors relativement récent ouais non mais
c'est vrai il faut le reconnaître quand
même parce que moi j'ai connu une époque
où quand même on ne pouvait pas tout
dire non moi aussi je les connais bon
maison pas dit grand chose
ils ont dit ce que tu leur as oui mais
toi tu as pu le faire ouais parce que
j'ai des couilles
non parce qu'il ya des gens qui t'ont
laissé faire
bonsoir facon soirs comme ça ça fait ça
fait folle ça c'est pas bien ah bon
bonsoir bonsoir
mais non ces bouts de guerre bonsoir
bonsoir
ils n'ont pas pas une petite voix de fos
et ça peut virer quand même
bonsoir bonsoir vous me dire bonjour
vraiment bonjour bonsoir bonsoir
l'émission est stupide
soir non ça va mal en chaleur non ça
c'est juste du type oui quelqu'un
préparer pour toi tu vas neveu terry de
la télévision voici celui qui laisse les
récompenses à terre pour mieux monter
aussi à lies célébrer les étoiles
frédéric mitterrand bonsoir
quand tu étais petit oui tu voulais tu
missionnaire week-end chef
démissionnaire et vous l'êtes pape oui à
la fin oui parce que je me suis dit que
je serais toujours là prix des grandeurs
mais nous préférions aussi je voulais
être finalement plus il fait ni l'un ni
l'autre mais s'attendait des bons
chrétiens nom des musulmans non non non
je la vérité si je ne crois pas en dieu
ne crois pas que tu crois pas j'ai moi
je regrette mais je crois pas à venir me
raconter ça d'accord oui
fédérer guillon
et
[Musique]
donc frédéric tu ne crois pas que je
pense que dieu est peut-être mais autres
cas certainement sans aucune des formes
que l'on nous a enseigné et et moi j'ai
sam finalement ça me cet affreux radio
mais ça m'intéresse pas est ce que ton
fils mathieu est baptisée wii il est
baptisé parce que
j'attache beaucoup d'importance ah au
fait qu'un enfant
[Musique]
soit comme les autres et ça fait partie
de notre culture de notre de notre vie
et après il est libre de faire ce qu'il
veut donc il ya des gens qui tiennent le
raisonnement inverse
moi j'ai préféré sud à lui accueille
maintenant il a 20 ans 21
on n'a jamais su si c'était ton ombre et
fils ou ton fils de 20 ans est tout à
fait mon vrai fils c'était une c'est à
dire que il a vécu avec moi d'une
manière un peu compliqué à cause du
désordre de la jeunesse qui était ma
jeunesse l'occurrence mais c'est mon
vrai fils et puis même si les témoins
fils adoptif il sera aussi membre et
fils toute façon je trouve terrible
cette différence la seule chose qui
compte c'est la manière dont les gens
s'occupent des autres mais
en tout cas c'est mon vrai fils est ce
que tu vois toujours sa mère
[Musique]
non parce que
la droite a tué beaucoup de gens qui l'a
élevé
je les ai élevés mais pas très bien
c'est à dire que je ne me suis pas assez
bien occupé que j'étais sans doute un
peu tyrannique avec lui je pêchais
d'inspirer quoi et
et voilà il faudrait lui demander à lui
si tu devais mourir là quelle serait la
seule chose que tu voudrais de vidéos à
ce moment là je t'aime
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
oh
et
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus